intense émotion hier au festival
d'avignon qui touche à sa fin une
vingtaine de comédiens réunis pour les
lettres de sarajevo
celles qui sont rassemblés justement
dans ce livre un livre publié chez liana
levi c'était une initiative de bernard
faivre d'arcier le prêt de directeur du
festival d'avignon qui avait invité son
homologue du festival de sarajevo
michel trudeau ici michel levasseur une
soirée à ne jamais oublier
l'émotion la vraie celle qui prend à la
gorge
cette nuit avignon lâchant de désespoir
et d'amour havas récitante ourdir
lettres d'habitants de sarajevo à
l'appui les fois je me sens complètement
coupée de tout ce que j'aime
je me demande si j'aurai l'occasion de
voir mon enfant
et si je pourrais te serrer encore dans
mes bras
cependant j'espère que cette guerre d'
absurde finira et que le temps viendra
où nous serons tous à nouveau uni j'ai
beaucoup du mal ma chérie à vivre sans
toi
et en même temps je suis heureux que tu
sois loin de toutes ces folies insensés
qui ont certes varier vous comme les
griffes
le pire c'est qu'on n'en voit pas la fin
c'est l'hiver la première neige est
tombé le 12 novembre la nourriture se
fait de plus en plus rares comme l'eau
l'électricité la ville est fermée de
tous les côtés pour les simplement tél
et on se sent comme dans un camp de
concentration
ce n'était pas un requiem mais malgré
tout un moment d'espoir cher grand-père
vous aimerez aimerions tellement te
revoir nous t'aimons tellement quelle
chance vous avez de vivre dans un
endroit où il y à la paix où sont passés
les temps heureux d'autrefois
qui aurait imaginé que viendrait la
guerre et que nous devrions nous écrire
des lettres
une nuit pour continuer de tisser les
liens pour ne pas abandonner les
encercler
fin de ce journal donc